and was hosted by the Asia Society in
New York City
give you a little introduction of my own
to this wonderful friend of mine
Anita Raghavan I first met her way back
in 1995 I was then with business India
magazine and I had come to New York and
I was looking around for stories to do
and I decided to do a story on Indian
journalists who were rising in the
mainstream business press and at that
time when I was interviewing all the
people who reached the top positions
someone said to me here you know there's
this reporter you must meet at the Wall
Street Journal her name is Anita
Raghavan and he described her as that
bright kid who's going places at that
time Anita was reporting on the
securities industry's securities
industria and well she did go places
because I met her again in you know just
a couple of years ago when our paths
crossed at Forbes and Anita was
appointed the London bureau chief and
now with this book I can assure you and
that Anita is going to go further afield
so Anita let's start off you know you've
been wanting to write about the you know
the whole South Asian Diaspora and why
did you choose this particular case what
was so compelling to tell that story at
this point in time well you know I I was
fascinated by the fact that Raj
Rajaratnam this Sri Lankan street
fighter had managed to seduce some of
the best and brightest of the Indian
American community you had Rajat Gupta
the three-time chairman of McKinsey Anil
Kumar his protege who had gone to some
of the finest schools in India the Doon
school IIT Delhi and I wanted to know
what was it that the Raj had that
managed to cast a spell over so many
of India's finest but don't you think
that you know in a sense it it it it was
not the brightest moment for the
community to be telling that story now
it wasn't but but but I think through
the story you were able to tell the tale
of the rise of the community because all
the individuals that are involved in
this case came you know post 1965 after
US immigration laws were relaxed and did
fantastically well in a very short
period of time and so you had the whole
trajectory of the community you know its
its highs and it's lows you know the
other thing I just wanted to ask you
I've been meaning to ask you the title I
just loved the title so how did you
really hone in on that particular title
well if I can start by saying we had
many titles before this title the first
title which was my favorite was sons of
the morning and it came from him that I
loved when I was in boarding school
because it captured this this idea of
the Indians that got the Indian American
elite that got caught up in this case as
being the best and the brightest of
India and I guess not everyone knew the
him from boarding school and so that was
quickly cast aside and and then we toyed
with two kings because Raj in a way was
the the king of wealth you know and and
Raja was a different sort of king a king
of thought he was a strategist from
McKinsey he had a sudden ability about
him and I I don't want to give away any
trade secrets but I think his [ __ ] was
selling another book with two Kings as
the title so so that quickly had to
to be a to be cast aside and finally you
know we wanted to focus a bit on on on
on you know what was this book about and
and I think we came to came to to the
idea amongst we came to the idea of the
billionaires apprentice because because
you know Roger at some point in his
career wanted to have what Raj
Rajaratnam
had and it was it was the billions well
I thought maybe you could read a little
bit from your book and you know that
sets the stage for a further discussion
okay
the passage I'm going to read from is
from the beginning of the book and it's
Rajat Gupta at the start of his life and
it tells you a little bit about Raja
then it also tells you about his father
who was a prominent freedom fighter who
spent many many years in jail a cousin
of Rajas told me when I was in Calcutta
interviewing her in 2011 she said Jail
was like a house to him so I'm going to
start with that ever since he was born
Rajat Kamal Gupta was likened to his
father he was as handsome as his father
with the same strikingly chiseled
jawline that gave both men a
distinguished heir a sense they belonged
to a secret world of privilege that went
beyond wealth intellect or bloodline in
a society with skin color was a defining
force but Rajat than his father Ashley
were fair-skinned a clear advantage that
afforded them a natural superiority both
were known for their generosity of
spirit and obliging way that over the
course of their lives would win them
steadfast friends and loyal followers
but beneath the surface the similarities
ended unlike his son Ashwini Kumar Gupta
came of age in an occupied country
seeming
we faded by his birth in 1908 to live in
deference to an imperial power as a
descendant of one of India's oldest
bloodlines arsh when he was also
ironically one of the chosen ones he
would be tapped and trained to deny his
Indian Asst and perform like a faux
Englishman all in the service of India's
Emperor Her Majesty the King while he
would receive a proper British education
like the other esteemed members of his
family
arjuna kumar gupta rejected intellectual
servitude on the morning of Thursday in
November the 5th 1964 ash Rooney's
eldest son 15 year old Rajat Kamal Gupta
dressed himself carefully draping his
best white dhoti of his body growing up
in a close-knit Indian family of four
children two girls and two boys
the youngest born after the family moved
to New Delhi in the 1950s Rajat was
accustomed to shouldering
responsibilities he and his older sister
were always looking after their younger
siblings by economic necessity his
parents were a two career couple long
before it was in vogue his mother taught
at the local Montessori School and upon
his release from prison
Ashwini took up journalism as a means to
support himself and his family his old
revolutionary ties to the leaders of a
newly free free India helped him rise
after India's independence he was
dispatched to start the Delhi edition of
The Hindustan Standard he was a frequent
visitor to Russia three bhavan the
official residence of the President of
India and it was well known among the
Delhi press corps that the country's
first Prime Minister travel all Nehru
called him by his first name so trusted
was Gupta by government ministers that
they would often seek his counsel on how
to deal with the press born as a British
subject oshri Gupta through hard work
and sacrifice became an insider in
modern India Rajat steel himself and
walked into the ante room of his uncle's
Calcutta home at 19 see Rajendra last
Street to say farewell shrouded with
heaps of roses marigold and fragrant
jasmine his father lay in a coffin as
was customary the body was washed in
purified water and dressed in
white kurta a loose-fitting shirt and a
white dhoti when he'd arrived at the
hospital the previous day he was told
that his father was dead but as he stood
at the entrance to his father's room he
saw a plastic bag still attached
bubbling with air from his father's last
gasps for a moment he thought the
doctors had made a mistake but the years
of struggle and incarceration had taken
their toll at fifty-six harshwhinny
Gupta was dead of kidney failure in the
months leading up to his father's death
young Rajat had spent a lot of time with
his father
accompanying him on long walks and
listening to stories of his time in the
freedom movement he learned that his
father had been intentionally exposed to
TB in prison which ultimately cost him
the use of one lung the ragged two-foot
long scar on his back came from his skin
being split open over and over again
during one particularly brutal
interrogation yet in spite of it all the
father he knew was kind and obliging to
everyone he would later recall he never
spoke ill of anybody and I would have
thought he would have had a lot of
resentment built into him but it wasn't
true this attitude was true of most of
my father's generation they were quite
extraordinary in terms of simple living
and high thinking and not thinking ill
of other people this morning in front of
Rajat uncle's house a crowd gathered
neighbors friends and admirers descended
like pilgrims on a sorrowful journey
door-to-door laundress Dobby men and
their donkey Dobby men and their donkeys
watched as a coffin was placed into a
glass top Hearst parked in front of the
red brick house with the green shutters
in tribute the Dobby man nudged their
donkeys away from the mourners and
solemnly cleared a path for the
procession at 9:00 a.m. the hearse
closely followed by cars carrying the
immediate family departed as a throng
approached the top of the street Roger
could make out a small shrine to Shiva
the Hindu god of destruction after a
stop at the offices of his father's
employers the newspaper group on in the
bazar patrika he led the crowd to white
town on the other side of town
Apurva Maitre Ashwin Gupte former Jayla
rash race to catch one final glimpse of
the man he ran to a crematorium known as
an EMTALA burning gut then South to the
Kerala tour of funeral parlor to no
avail
on his last guest he found the right
destination clenching a fistful of
flowers he elbowed through a crowd of
hundreds of friends family and wiring
strangers and made his way beyond the
row of bodies stacked in a line to be
cremated at last after pushing his way
past Ashwini Gupta's brother the former
prison guard made it to the coffin
Ashwini Gupta's teenage son Raja was
just completing the final death right in
the silence that followed Maitre was
able to place what was left of his bunch
of lotus flowers on the feet of his
fallen friend Rajat Gupta then helped
roll the stretcher holding his beloved
father's body into the orange flames of
Calcutta's electric crematorium overcome
with grief matron muttered a prayer to
his dead friend
Ashwini pray not a grain of hatred
remains mingled in your ashes I tried to
atone for my sin if he hadn't been
unwashed in his own sadness at the
premature death of one of India's unsung
heroes maître might have heard another
voice the tender voice of Rajat Kamal
Gupta quietly beseeching a higher power
who will show me the way in the world
Anita you know this is an incredible
amount of rich detail and really it
makes your hair stand on in how how
difficult was it
you know researching and reporting this
book I mean what sort of reactions were
you getting because obviously the
backdrop was this whole you know insider
trading scandal so you know you've been
a very dogged reporter but writing a
book of this scale and this depth what
was the experience like it was it was
very difficult because so many members
of the Indian American community who had
helped me on many many stories before
were quite reluctant to speak about this
story because in a way it cost such a
such a poor light you know on the
community and and I think the Diaspora
didn't want to draw attention to it so
you know I really had to tap old sources
and convince them that that while this
was a shadow on the community it also in
a sense reflected the vibrancy of the
community in the United States today the
fact that you know we have prosecutors
and people who mete out justice as part
of you know the the part of American
society is a sign of strength you know
when my parents came and when I grew up
here in the 70s for part of the time you
know Indians were confined to being
doctors and engineers and college
professors today we have movie makers we
have writers and and of course
you know prosecutors like Preet Bharara
and at the SEC Sanjay Wadhwa it's a much
more diverse that's right so you know
being an Indian yourself was was that a
help or hindrance I mean what what did
it bring into the story I think it was a
advantage in the sense that that I
understood some of the dynamics of the
story you know the the communal
differences you know the difference
between a sri lankan and and an Indian
or or Rumi Khan who who was a Hindu
married to to a Muslim and who Midway if
you've read the book midway in the
scandal starts having marital problems
and goes over to another Indian friend's
home to pray and it's because he's a
Hindu unlike a husband who is a who's a
Muslim so I think it helped in in
understanding you know the the cultural
forces that played a big role in this
story it was also a challenge though
because you know one of the one of the
central protagonists of the of the book
is of course Rajat Rajat Gupta and here
we're here with me someone of the
community writing a book that was going
to to shine a spotlight if you will on
on his missteps and how did you do that
how do you do that in a way that that
you know doesn't open you up to
accusations of you know just taking down
a hero and and I was I was cognizant of
that as I wrote the book you know in
fact a large part of the book I mean
your portrait of Gupta comes across you
know he comes across as a really upright
figure and very principled and you know
had absolutely on that position right to
the top ranks of the kinsey what do you
think you know since you've really gone
into this in such detail what was the
tipping point I mean why
I mean that's the question everyone
wants to know why yeah I think you know
there were a number of factors but you
have to remember that Rajat Gupta had
built up his career in the hinterlands
in a way you know he'd been in
Scandinavia he'd been in Chicago and
late in life in the in the late 90s he
comes to New York and he's thrust into
this new meliha and it's a bit of a
bright lights big city phenomenon he's
suddenly mingling with Henry Kravis and
Hank Paulson and you know I think he in
some way looked at his you know 30-year
career as a McKinsey salary man and and
said what do I have to show for it and
it's very interesting you know all of
the the descent if you will happens
after he steps down from the helm of
McKinsey you know he becomes closer to
rajaratnam in 2005 and in 2004 you know
he gives this talk at Columbia and and
you know I've watched a tape of the
talking and you have the sense of a man
really casting about trying to figure
out what was he going to do how was he
going to you know achieve a new high and
I think he was really struggling so that
success at McKinsey was not not enough
not enough so he was far more ambitious
right but you know when I read I read
the book of course a nita and I was up
nights yet it was so gripping it's like
you know it's like a novel it's like you
know this great Shakespearean tragedy
but when I read it I I got the sense
that you know there is an underlying
sympathy that you have for Rajat Gupta
that you know may not have been the case
it in your interpretation of Rajaratnam
man Anil Kumar was his colleague but
underlying you know a huge wave of
sympathy for him is that correct or am i
mr. bean that's why I wanted to read you
the passage I did because um you know
the picture of Rajat that we all saw
over the last several years was was a
very stoic man you know he was a
signifies statesman and I you know when
I went to Calcutta to interview members
of his family and luckily I went there
before you know he was indicted and they
spoke to me very openly and I said you
know was Raja affected at all by his
father's death because you know he
hardly ever talked talked about it he
his first roommate and Mackenzie told me
that he didn't even know that
Rajat was an orphan and his cousin said
to me of course he was you know he was
wandering around in a in a comatose
state
you know he had he had hopped on a train
you know from New Delhi and and come to
Calcutta you know when he'd found out
that his father was very ill and and the
moment he learned he died he was just
you know in a daze so you know when you
meet I mean you met almost 200 people
it's researching this book sorry I'm on
the phone nothing okay well I'm glad to
know that I thought you were superhuman
but you know you talk to 200 people and
then you hear all these different voices
pros and cons and so how do you sift
through all that how do you arrive at
you know a true and fair picture that
you know reflects reality you must have
got a lot of static as well yeah I mean
there's certainly there was certainly a
core of people at McKinsey who also did
not like Rajat who thought he had taken
the firm in the wrong direction who
argued that you could have actually
predicted what happened
um I felt you know the the crime if you
will was so had gotten such press and
and Rajat had suffered so much as a
result of the crime you know I think his
lawyer Gary enough Dallas you know at
the end of the trial said you know this
is a Greek tragedy of epic proportions
and so to me what was more interesting
about this story was was who was the man
who was the the human who ended up in
this very bad place
yeah because despite him being so
high-profile and you know written about
extensively and I remember you know
meeting Rajat on several occasions
interviewing him you know even visiting
him at his home and I thought oh my god
you know this is it this is what success
means he he had the golden life but
there was always that that that sort of
barrier I mean he always kept you know a
part of him which is very private right
so I think you know you were able to
sort of penetrate that through through
this book right did you find that
difficult I mean was it I mean were
people you know from his past you know
you've met
I know his secretary his you know you
used every source was that you know
difficult for you or I think I think
going to Calcutta was was very helpful
in understanding Rajat because you know
his cousins spoke very freely and and
they knew the young Rajat you know who
is rather a precocious child I mean I
remember a story about how apparently on
one family trip he got on he got on the
roof of the car and and he wouldn't he
wouldn't climb down and they had to ply
him with sweets before he would come
down
you know and and you got the sense of a
boy who was who was quite alive and then
suddenly when he was sixteen he loses
his parents and his did you know his
whole persona changes and you know I
think that struck me well going to this
case now moving fast forward do you
think that you know the whole economic
meltdown of 2008 sort of made this you
know you know cause this whole case to
escalate the way it did do you think you
know that escalation was justified you
know a lot of South Asians have asked me
you know do you think Indians were
targeted you know in this case why
aren't they catching you know the real
culprits of the financial crisis and you
know you know prosecutors are probably
not too different from the rest of us
you know in the way they do their job
you know if there is a if there's an
easy case to bring and this was an easy
case to bring once you had wiretaps of
Raj Rajaratnam you know receiving inside
information from various players you
know if you have an easy case to bring
you will you will bring an easy case and
you know trying to prosecute the the the
creators of the mortgage fraud debacle
is far harder you know you can you can
probably bring cases against brokers who
sold these shoddy mortgages but how do
you tie these brokers to the heads of
the investment banks it's very difficult
there are too many layers to penetrate
and and I think this was just an easy
case to bring do you think the sentence
was too harsh for both of them or
you know you know I don't want to
comment on the sentence but but you know
because I don't feel it's my my role to
but you know again I think that a lot of
people have remarked to me you know
don't you think
Rajat Gupta got you know a severe
sentence and I actually think Rajat
Gupta was very lucky getting a sense he
did if he was before another judge I
think he would have gotten many more
years because in a way the crime he
committed was far more serious than the
one that Raj Rajaratnam
committed he was a he was a board member
he had a fiduciary responsibility to
keep the secrets of the board in the
board room well in a sense you know in
India back home people in power have a
sense of entitlement and you know almost
expect immunity this kind of thing would
not have happened do you think that that
sense of entitlement is something that
you know they bring here as well or are
they well aware of the consequences I
mean you know this kind of very blatant
behavior that comes across in your book
I mean what what made them believe they
could get away with this is it to do
with that that sort of Indian ethos of
you know power giving you immunity I'm
not sure it has anything to do with the
Indian ethos because you know one of
Rogers best friends Bill Clinton also
thought he was untouchable
so
so you know I think I think it's just
one of the attendant attributes of power
you know you you you have you have a
sense of invincibility and I think Rajat
had gotten to that point in life you
know where he really thought he was you
know not going to be affected by this
and here I'm thinking about a lot of
reporting I did in the early months when
Rajat first found out he had a problem
and and his reaction to finding this out
was not to be really concerned and I
think it's because he didn't think it
would come to much I was wondering if
you could read a little bit you know and
give us a flavor of of that time when he
was really at the peak at the office of
his career and okay okay this is this as
as you said Nazneen is when Rajat Gupta
is at the height of his power and it's
just before actually he finds out he may
have a problem it's his first inkling
but I won't get to that I'll just keep
him out of it his height of his power
it was Tuesday November 24th 2009 and
rajesh kumar gupta was headed to the
White House for the first state dinner
hosted by President Barack Obama and his
wife Michelle the most glamorous
political couple since the Kennedys six
years had passed since Gupta had stepped
down as the three-term global managing
director of consulting giant McKinsey
but at 60 he was busier than ever he sat
on a handful of corporate boards Goldman
Sachs Procter & Gamble and American
Airlines to name a few his wife Anita
had hoped his retirement from the top
job at McKinsey would slow him down but
he was in the throes of building his own
private equity company from scratch
jetting from continent to continent
living out of a suitcase he was as
intent on being a game changer in
private equity in philanthropy as he had
been during a storied career in
insulting dressed in a black narrow suit
with a red handkerchief tucked in his
pocket
Gupta made his way to the white tent on
the South Lawn from the gilded East room
which served as a staging area for the
dinner at every turn he ran into friends
he chatted with Deepak Chopra the
new-age physician who was wearing his
signature gem studded eyeglasses for the
glittering gala he mingled with free
turbans all a top lawyer in the new
administration and caught up with Bobby
Jindal a former McKinsey consultant and
now the Republican governor of Louisiana
Jindal whose given name is Pioche was
born in Baton Rouge his parents migrated
to America from the Indian state of
Punjab six months before he was born
Jindal was typical of the guests at the
White House at night while the
extensible purpose of the evening was to
honor the Indian Prime Minister Dr
Manmohan Singh the event also served as
a barometer for how far and how fast an
immigrant group had risen in one
generation Indian Americans had bolted
from geeky Outsiders to polish players
in all facets of American society
if Gupta wanted to make small talk in
the security line with a fortune 500 CEO
he could approach either jeez Jeffrey
Immelt or in the renewing the CEO of
PepsiCo who was born and bred in Chennai
if he wanted to bask in the reflected
glow of a TV presenter he could chat
with Katie Couric or the Mumbai born
Fareed Zakaria Hollywood was represented
at the event both Steven Spielberg and
the Indian director of The Sixth Sense M
night Shyamalan whose birthplace is
Pondicherry we're in attendance that
night as one of the pioneering Indian
success stories in the United States
hooked on you almost all the Indian
invitees and as a McKinsey legend their
non-indian counterparts too he had
worked with many and served as a mentor
to others when neil kumar kajal the
principal Deputy Solicitor General was
in high school and getting pressure from
his Indian parents to study medicine
Gupta advised him to follow his dreams
cartels position in the Justice
Department is one of the chief attorneys
representing the government before the
US Supreme Court was a testament to the
heights to which Indians had risen in
American society as you looked around
the room that night it was breathtaking
to see the diversity and depth of talent
says Timothy Jay
Roma at the time the US ambassador to
India there were CEOs and entrepreneurs
there were doctors hotel owners and
writers there were aspiring office
seekers and office holders there were
people who had grown up poor in India
but now they were the CEO of the company
you could feel how alive the American
Dream was in that room exalts Roma there
was never any question that Gupta would
be invited he was one of the few Indians
in America who waltz through vastly
different worlds business and
philanthropy Indian America without ever
losing a step he was friends with almost
all the Indian businessmen accompanying
dr. Singh on his trip to the United
States he was close to Mukesh Ambani the
head of the powerful Indian conglomerate
Reliance Industries who viewed Gupta as
one of India's most treasured exports
someone who had reached the pinnacle of
corporate and public life in the United
States but had never lost his affection
for his homeland he knew Ratan Tata
often described as the David Rockefeller
of India Tata whose holdings run the
gamut from cars Jaguar Land Rover to
Hotels Mumbai's iconic Taj Mahal Palace
Hotel had worked early on to help to
turn his dream of an Indian business
school into reality but cooked his most
important relationship one that
certainly helped secure an invitation
that evening was his French friendship
with the guest of honor dr. Singh Gupta
was one of the few Indian executives in
America who could get the Indian Prime
Minister on the phone on short notice
despite Mackenzie's prominence in India
the two were not acquainted in the early
90s when Gupta was a rising star at
McKinsey and Singh then a little-known
finance minister in a previous Indian
government was the architect of
fusillade of economic reforms that
dismantled the red tape raj and ushered
in an era of entrepreneurial freedom but
when india prospered in the wake of
singh's reforms McKinsey thrived
advising a raft of Indian companies on
restructuring moves and playing a
pivotal role in building offshore Astana
it was during Gupta's time as managing
director that McKinsey opened its
groundbreaking knowledge center in a
suburb of New Delhi hiring a fleet of
Indian researchers many with MBAs to
analyse important trends such as
cellular phone penetration from McKinsey
consultants when the McKinsey knowledge
center turned out to be a huge hit
went global with the idea he preached
the sermon of offshoring to American
companies eager to cut costs and push
them to send more and more of their back
office work and support work Corporate
Research legal transcription and
financial analysis to India clients were
thrilled and in India Gupta was a
corporate rock star just as recognizable
in Mumbai as Jamie Dimon is in New York
it was no small irony then that one of
his dinner companions at the White House
that evening was Labour leader and Andy
Stern the president of the company's
second largest Union Stern whose
organization spent the most money
supporting Obama sat between Gupta and
his wife Anita at a table sumptuous
sumptuously decorated with gold charger
plates in purple and magenta
arrangements of roses sweet peas and
hydrangeas on green apple tablecloths
over a dinner of green curry green curry
prawns collard greens and coconut aged
basmati rice stern took the opportunity
to nudge a key party some consider
responsible for the fading prospects of
the American worker
he pressed Gupta on white companies like
Goldman whose investors include public
pension plans didn't have more regard
for the worker in his soft-spoken but
firm way Gupta insisted they did they
gave a lot of money away to needy
organizations but Stan had something
more radical in mind profits more
broadly distributed to rank-and-file
employees overhearing the debate would
Gupta's dinner companions Treasury
Secretary Timothy Geithner and North
Dakota Senator Kent Conrad
it was heady company if anyone had told
Gupta back when he was a little boy in
Calcutta that he would someday work at
let alone run McKinsey and be invited to
the White House for dinner they might
have had an easier time convincing him
that he would walk on the moon the
heights he had attained would only serve
to make the events that followed all the
more unfathomable Anita I know you're
going to close that book but you know
there's that you refer to that in
particular time when you know the first
goal came right from Goldman Sachs right
from their legal counsel and I thought
that was you know that's his reaction
there I think was
you know he's rushing through the
airport he's you know it's just it
doesn't really sink in and it's not the
reaction of somebody who's you know done
something wrong it's clearly the
reaction of somebody who's innocent so
how do you square that reaction with you
know the final conviction I don't think
even to this day he really believes he
he did something something wrong and I
think I square that reaction my take on
on his his attitude to Greg Palm the
Goldman general counsel who calls him
and says you know we we've heard the the
feds are investigating investigating you
for tipping Raj Rajaratnam I I talked
his reaction up to sort of an arrogance
of a belief that that you know if this
is a problem it's going to go away I'm
too powerful to be touched a bit like
Bill Clinton you know entertaining
someone in the in the Oval Office and
and thinking you know no one will hear
of it yeah
do you think you could just read a
couple of graphs from their flag palm
the Greg I just think you know that it's
it's so sort of sets the stage for the
book if you can locate that pass it
sorry to spring it on you like that but
no no you know thinking back on the book
I think that is important for the
audience to understand sure you know
where he started from and then how how
it up finally unravels
absolutely absolutely um why don't you
while while I'm finding the passage here
in the book isn't it earlier
well the earlier part is when Greg when
Greg finds out that there's a problem
goes to blank fine that's that's earlier
but but Gupta's reaction to it is is
actually
later Gupta's actual reaction to it I
mean he's rushing through he's the you
want the conversation and that's later
so yeah okay so but if you'd like to ask
me something while I'm finding that okay
well you know you talked about you know
casting a bad light on the community
there's this this in this whole case
does it call into question the whole you
know Indians success story so to speak
in the United States is it is it going
to make it that much harder for the next
generation to reach the heights that
Roger did you know Indians have had a
magical journey in the United States you
know they came in ever greater numbers
starting in the starting in the 70s
after the Lyndon Johnson reforms and
they in one generation have you know
gone on to become top lawyers in this
country today we're at a point where
shree not the Srinivasan you know is
likely to become a federal appeals court
judge in DC and as you can tell from the
opening passage we had you know movie
makers politicians and I do think the
the scandal involving Rajat and some of
the other Indian luminaries will cast a
shadow on the community for a while I
remember when I started writing this
book I was at a gala and a prominent
Indian American who heads a bank came up
to me and he said Anna the white why
this book why this buck and you could
tell that that on some level his own
sense of security felt threatened by
this this episode even though he had
nothing to do with it well you know I
was just as so ironical that you know
you mentioned in your afterward in the
book that you know Anil Kumar someone
like Anil Kumar where there was a clear
money trail and a link between him and
Roger odd numbers that was not the case
with Rajat I mean you just you know came
to a conclusion because they were
business partners and therefore you know
indirectly he's benefiting but in onion
Kumar's case clearly there was a payoff
and you know he just sang like a canary
and got away and so it seems somehow you
know totally unfair and as you right now
that he's you know probably getting a
second career back home so I do you
think that's you know Raja themes could
rehabilitate himself back home quite
easily oh I think it's very likely he
will you know I was speaking recently to
someone an American who had just come
back from India and he said it's
interesting that while the press in the
United States about Rajat is
overwhelmingly negative in in India he's
something of a hero he is somebody who
has been who has been mistreated by an
unjust US legal system so I think Rajat
will very easily rehabilitate himself in
in India no question well like would you
like to could you just show us for a
minute this is this actually is 17 days
after the first scene at the White House
that I read from and Gupta is about -
he's at Philadelphia International
Airport and he's about to board a plane
and he gets a call from Greg pom who is
the general counsel of Goldman Sachs
palm caught up with Gupta as he was at
the airport palm started off his call
with Gupta on December 11th 2009 with
two unusual disclosures tip offs that
the conversation they were about to have
would be uncomfortable and could
potentially make Goldman Gupta
adversaries palm talk after that he'd
arranged to have a colleague on his line
listen in on their conversation
typically palm like to have one-on-one
conversations but he had decided that
since topic was very sensitive it was
important that there be an extra set of
years and an extra pair of hands to
record exactly what was said and to
monitor Gupta's reaction if Gupta still
had not registered that this call would
be different from any other that he had
had with the Goldman official palm said
something else that should have put him
on notice we're representing the
corporation and not you palm told him
palm wanted to make sure that there was
no doubt and cooked his mind that this
was not a privileged conversation that
would be protected by lawyer-client
confidentiality if the matter involved
into something much bigger as pom was
expecting the contents of his
conversation with Gupta could be handed
over to law enforcement officers
investigating the matter how can you
what can you tell me about Raj
Rajaratnam
and have you ever provided him with
information about what we do pom asked
sticking to a script that he had worked
out before the call Gupta was clearly
taken aback by the question not entirely
sure what pom was driving at what are
you talking about he asked pom explained
to Gupta the Goldman had come to learn
they go to may have been in contact with
Rajaratnam and provided him with
information about the firm Gupta did not
fly off the handle or turn evasive he
comported himself in exactly the way pom
and others at Goldman had grown to
expect very calmly and cerebral
cerebrally he denied that he had ever
provided Rajaratnam with confidential
information about Goldman then he went
on to explain why the charge was
preposterous
he told palm and the other Goldman
lawyer who was listening in that he and
Rajaratnam at one time had been business
partners on a venture called New Silk
Route but the two had had a falling-out
and when
no longer close their partnership their
parting had stemmed from a soured
investment that Gupta had entered into
many years of back Gupta said he had
poured ten million into an investment
vehicle with Rajaratnam who had invested
more money in the entity rajaratnam
Gupta said he later learned had taken
his money out meanwhile Gupta's 10
million investment had gone to zero
Gupta said he had hired accountants and
lawyers and was planning to sue
Rajaratnam but then the Galleon chief
was arrested why would I help out
someone with whom I had a dispute he
asked rhetorically thanks Amita you know
just a couple of more questions final
questions before we open it up to the
floor you know you've kept one very
interesting juicy part of the story
right at the end and I don't want to I
don't want to disclose that because
really that's something that Anita's
uncovered which is not common knowledge
at all but I can disclose the title of
the chapter is called family secret and
you know it's a pretty explosive secret
which gives a different you know
complexion to cook those background and
what he ultimately what ultimately
happened so I'm going to not disclose
the secret because you know we want you
to buy the book but rather we want you
to enjoy the book to read the book but
you know how did you ever chance upon
this this was actually common knowledge
in Calcutta and no one no one really
wrote about it out of deference to
cooked his father who was a journalist
and of course I wasn't going to write
about it based on the chatter but
I had at my disposal in London the
wonderful archives of the British
Library and I had a sense of when this
incident happened and so I started
looking through old newspapers and I
found out that I found out that this was
a this incident this episode was a cause
celebra in Calcutta in the 1930s and
newspapers ran daily stories about the
incident and it caused great shame and
dishonor to Gupta's family because so
many of them was steeped in in the in
education in academia and but even
though it was rumored about by going to
Calcutta I interviewed a number of
people who knew Gupta's father who were
very old and I learned of the
circumstances of what what really
happened and I hope in I hope I felt it
was important to include this story
because you know I think it was this
this burden the family had carried for
so many years and and you know everybody
was aware of it you know people talked
about it in hushed tones they said you
know he did something he should have
never done we're speaking about Gupta's
father and I think it cast a pall over
Rajat and his siblings yet yet there was
there was something very honourable in
in the dishonor the parallels there so
finally Anita Watts
what's the key takeaway from this whole
saga what what are the you know what
some would say that you know this
really paints Indians in a bad light but
how do you view it I mean what what what
would you like the readers to understand
this book yes I think it's a I think it
shows that we as a community have
arrived in America we are finally large
enough in number we are economically
significant and as a result we we now
have our own crime that will be
prosecuted there will be episodes like
this from time to time but if anything
to me it's it's a celebration of the
community strength rather than its
weakness I think we can open it up to
the floor now and I'm sure we'll have
lots of questions do we have a mic
please come forward
just briefly introduce yourself Thank
You Khalid Rahman I'm a physician from
New York both of you are from Wall
Street so kind of insiders does this
happen I thought it was in terms of the
large street does the inside trading
happen much more often and just few
people get caught or this is just a
relatively rare phenomenon you want me
to answer I need that I think there are
waves and and I think insider trading is
rampant it probably happens less often
today than it did in 2008 and 2009 but I
think it's a common feature of you know
the landscape of Wall Street and it's
inevitable because because you have you
know so much information sloshing around
and some of it is is truly confidential
information and some of it is pure rumor
so yes I think it's it's an endemic
problem on Wall Street you're right up
front here on the frost row please thank
you thank you very much a most
insightful a story extraordinary and the
timing of it it's just Christie darlings
my name I have a question will you be
able to distribute the book into your
country yes I think so
yes I think there are plans afoot to do
that at some point where the world's
greatest democracy a lot of things in
India that you can't do in many unless
you're writing about a business group
they might buy up all the copies it just
happened in the past I think right there
and even quite perplexed by the fact you
said Preet Bharara try to pick the
low-hanging fruit when he went after
Raja intriguing part is there's not one
shred of evidence presenting presented
the wholesome responsible in spite of
all the hours of wiretapping is not one
shred of evidence you don't find that
funny well again you know a lot of South
Asians focus on evidence is being a
wiretap you have to remember this is the
first case where wiretaps were used to
prosecute insider trading insider
trading has been prosecuted for the last
20 years with circumstantial evidence
and I don't know if you sat through the
trial as I did but but the
circumstantial evidence was quite
compelling by that you mean the timing
of the phone calls the timing of the
phone calls just after the board
meetings and you know on on the day the
let's talk about the goldman sachs
warren buffett warren buffett investment
those type of circumstantial for
beneficiaries of those transactions
there have been no link that we project
and him receiving any funds of any of
those transactions so I'm not sure that
issue no that's not right actually there
was a case in 2008 against a Credit
Suisse banker the US Attorney's Office
could not at trial show that money had
gone to the banker there was no no
benefit they were trying to allege that
there was a man in Pakistan who you know
may have gotten some some money and he
was kicking it back to the Credit Suisse
banker but there was no actual display
of it and you know benefit is a very
nebulous term in insider trading cases
and it doesn't have to be
you know money hand it over in suitcases
like you know Mart Marty Segal received
in the late 80s it can be benefit as you
know you know general business business
ties will lead to greater business in
fact there's a little description in the
book about the judge saying that you
know there were no suitcases of cash so
it was you know this was not as exciting
a trial as the previous one is can we
just have yeah good night okay it's a
simple psychological question was
records father a financial failure
because of that he was determined to
prove the exact opposite thereby and all
this grief came from there
Roger Roger was from a very came from
very humble roots and when his father
came out of jail there's a there's a
document in the British Library that I
uncovered he he had I mean a thousand is
either sorry I'm doing this from memory
it was it was something like ten
thousand rupees in debt which is an
enormous amount of money for that time
and and read it again in this talk that
he gave at Columbia he said that you
know how his father was someone if
anyone asked for his shirt off his back
he would give it to them and he said we
were we were very lucky because had it
not been for for a mother who put aside
some money you know we would have been
starving we would have been on the
street when our parents died so I do
think you know he grew up at a very
young age learning the importance of the
security that came from from wealth
right
hello hi and I wanted to ask you uh you
had said that you believe that this
scandal these problems are going to
reflect badly upon the South Asian
community I know that the Economist
magazine disagreed with that finding
although they found your book to be
extraordinarily well-written they said
that that analysis was in their minds
quote-unquote nonsense I wanted to know
why you think the actions of two people
it's going to reflect badly upon three
million in this country or a billion
worldwide that's one question if you and
if you can if you if you can answer the
question that if why was it in your
investigative journalism did you find
that
why were these two wiretapped if this is
not a standard practice and no one else
has ever been wired chapter prosecuted
based on wiretaps
why were these two Roger Ratnam and
Rajesh Gupta wiretapped and and and I'm
sorry but lastly as a Sri Lankan I must
ask you when you talk about the Indian
diaspora are you including all South
Asians in your analysis or just or just
people from from India okay let me
answer question two first why were these
two wiretap they weren't the only two
wiretapped
you know Daniel Kaz was wiretap fee
golfer was wiretap there were a number
other 's wiretapped they even tried to
get not a wiretap but they in the in the
summer of 2009 tried to get a former
associate of Stevie Cohen to to record
him in incriminating conversations and
he didn't take the bait - you're quoting
three my book you know while raj was
obviously the person who you know was
the catalyst if you will I was really
focused on the Indian diaspora Rajat
Gupta unhealed Kumar because you know
these were individuals who who were the
best and brightest
of the indian community you know they
went to the establishment schools they
joined the establishment companies they
were very different from raj who was
actually on the fringes of Wall Street
he was on need he was it need him before
he started galleon and he became a
success through galleon and to your
first question I think you know when I
when I when when the adaptation of my
book ran in the New York Times I read a
number of the comments and I find
comments to stories more fascinating
these days than even the stories
actually and it was stunning to me but
there were there were a number of people
who who said essentially what do you
expect these are these are South Asians
or you know so I do think it will have
it will have an effect on the community
I'm not saying you know by the same
token you know I did did mention that
you know Srinivasan is probably going to
be confirmed for the federal appeals
court in DC it's not devastating but it
will it will in the short term I think
you know particularly on Wall Street
know yeah he's been confirmed by the
Senate but just you know follow on from
there and it'll you think you know in
another context I mean back home so to
speak would you know Raj and Rajat ever
you know what their parts ever cross
would they be friends I mean would they
have you know did you seen it like two
different I don't I personally don't
think I personally don't think they
would have you know and look at you know
you know they weren't they weren't
friends outside of business they didn't
they didn't socialize together
you know Roger didn't go to Rogers you
know 50th birthday party in Kenya this
was a marriage of mutual interest you
know for a particular period of time
Oh Drive back there second circuit
argument you were there and I presume I
saw you
yes for the ROG and they yeah they yeah
so you were there for Rajat Gupta oh no
I was not there you're not there but he
wrote a piece on Hindu business my
business like yeah okay you will and I
am right okay yeah I had someone there
okay I was there let me just ask you
very quickly there are three points the
two time wiretaps September 24th and
October 24th right and the argument is
there hearsay right October 24th seems
to be accepted young baby Tortola US
Attorney's Office kind of conceding it
but there's no September there's no
September 24th wiretap there's only an
October 23 stupid 23rd or 24th when
that's not a wiretap that's just a phone
call okay
record in the big one is the Gitanjali
is extended testimony i privated was an
extended to me the climate feels very
difficult for Roger than that piece code
right and John human right ask the
question with this Nov so what is your
take on it
in terms of in terms of what you heard
from the appellate court what tea leaves
theory right I mean obviously it's a
panel of three judges I think one of the
judges is seen to be generally Pro the
defense just my reporting of the judge
the other judge is yes that's right yeah
and this the other judge is pro pro
prosecution and I think that's right and
John Newman
yes but John Newman I think Rogers for
lawyers really look to John Newman as
being kind of the wild card and someone
you know because he's very
intellectually rigorous and and I think
they came away disappointed by the
questions he asked budgets lawyers came
okay discipline yeah right there yeah
sorry
our next over here the second row after
them I am my name is Niall Mohammed she
would see the two thousand 2020 well
Richard was the managing partner there
and just speaking of somebody who was at
McKinsey and and knowing a lot of
colleagues there the sense of betrayal
of Rajat Gupta is so acute it's
mind-boggling you know a firm like
Mackenzie and I'm sure all the big
consulting firms you know your absolute
key is client confidentiality to the
extent that ten years eight years after
left McKinsey I still don't talk about
who my clients were even though they
don't exist anymore so that's the first
point the second point is you know
impact on South Asians a lot of
consultants McKinsey consultants who
indian-origin have you know in just a
chatter that goes across the networks
have solved that now they'll be set up
for special scrutiny they kind of feel
like they part of the Indian mafia at
McKinsey and that there's cows and a
disparaging shadow on them and I'm not
saying it's gonna be widespread oh it's
be long-lasting but this certainly is a
bit of that impactor
so I was wondering good well I need any
specific question okay right here in the
second row please yeah hi my name is
Harish choke and my question is I take
it you didn't speak to or interview
Rajat for this book I'm not going to
comment on you no I don't want to
comment on sources okay and and I'm also
my and I'm also little kind of perplexed
to that if you were talking to his
family members or cousins in Calcutta
did they know the subject material of
the book obviously you start putting him
in a good light they did I mean they
they they were vainly giving all this
information well it was I mean a lot of
the book is about you know I think
Nazneen and various other people have
said that it's a very sympathetic
portrayal of him so you know that's what
they contributed to and one last thing
about this this wiretap this
conversation that he had after the board
meeting of Gorman has that been is that
on tape or now no there's no wiretap but
what I was answering the previous
gentleman's question what I was trying
to say is that this is the first case
where wiretaps have been have been used
and there have been insider trading
cases brought in the 80s in the 90s you
know postman on millennium against you
know Caucasians and others and all of
them have been brought using
circumstantial evidence and they the the
Credit Suisse banker that I mentioned
where there was no no benefit was shown
there was just this allegation that this
man was tipping someone in Pakistan who
was placing trades this man was
sentenced to eight years in prison on
circumstantial evidence but only that
wasn't there one phone call oh you know
that conversation is in July 29 2008
where he says where he talks you know
Raj is sort of complaining about an elk
and saying you know I give him a million
bucks for what and Rajat says well he
should be more thankful and you know
he's hardly paying attention right so
wasn't that that was a that was a
wiretap conversation but that was not a
charged that was not part of the charges
because you know the information being
passed did not rise to material
nonpublic no one particular the one for
which is charged immediately or the
board meeting on September 23rd yeah
that's right that wasn't on the tape or
white tab because they're only what this
came during the came up during the
hearing wrong that he put an asked
exactly that right and he is what Roger
I mean rajaratnam really cell phone was
tapped but not the home phone and the
office not all is not tell about this
for informed thank you so they don't
have it on the team that put it here in
sync enrollments and John likes me for
manager oh you do title this book have
been the rise of Rajat Gupta and the
fall of galleon fund rather than the
rise of the Indian American elite I've
not read the book yet but I looked at
the table of contents and read the
excerpt in new york times and looks like
it's all about reject good not about the
american indian american elite in
general about Vinod Khosla sanjay gupta
Sreekanth universe and all of this many
elites that gone up it and and in
titling books like this that way perhaps
you're going to cause a self-fulfilling
prophecy if casting a shadow over the
whole diaspora no I think all I was
trying to do was was you know I think
Rajat Gupta was an important member of
the of the community and I think his his
journey was similar to to the journey of
many in the community the rise the
explosive rise in such a short period of
time and you know sometimes you use one
character to to show what a community is
done you know
and and I think certainly his rise was
emblematic of the communities in this
book is one of what his fault is right
device I think I actually think the book
is I think the book spends a lot of time
on his rise oh really okay also the time
you know we can count pages later yeah
and the title of the book is the
billionaires apprentice so you know it's
clearly about one person in that sense
but placed in the broader context I mean
that's how I understood it right there
James that kkona hi good evening my name
is Megha Lal and I'm part of that wave
of diaspora
you spoke about that came in the 1960s
and although I have not read your book I
find that it takes a tremendous amount
of courage and strength for us as a
diaspora to be reflective and look back
at ourselves and despite all of our
strengths and all of the success we've
had I think it's very important for our
growth to also recognize some of the
things that we have not done with good
ethics and have not conducted ourselves
in the way in which we should so thank
you for that my question related to that
is what insight or perspective would you
offer to the next generation of diaspora
that is up and coming
now that is applying to college and
looking at their career path what
perspective could you offer I actually
think they they have an advantage that
that certainly my parents generation
which is the same generation as really
registeration
didn't have and they grew up in the
United States and they are they are
assimilated and you know they I think
have a better appreciation of the the
rigidity if you
of you know laws in the United States
the lack of lack of gray you know and I
think that's why you know this is a
story about South Asians but it's also a
story of two different generations of
South Asians you know Rajat Gupta Anil
Kumar they were one generation and even
though Preet Bharara was born in India
he he came here when he was two and he's
a he's a different generation and I
think you know what we're seeing is you
know I think the assimilated Indian will
be very successful in this country I
don't think they need any advice for me
hi my name is party mukerjea and I
attended the rutted Gupta trials last
summer and was fascinating just seeing
the whole family and you know whether it
was acting or a genuine grief and regret
going along but I would like a little
more on the tipping point that you
brought up very early in the
conversation where in that Colombia
speech that you referenced he seemed
confused about what's the next day how
to go higher
how does wanting to hang out with Henry
Kravis and that kind of sophisticated
billionaire glamorous set and at the
same time wanting a little more money
via Rajaratnam yay I just don't
understand how rajaratnam won the poll
that instead of wanting to be in that
elite class of sophisticated
billionaires how is it simply greed by
your analysis is it simply greed that
attracted Rajat Gupta to and like this
gentleman here you know I never heard on
tape anything any words from Rajib's to
say that he had actually given the tips
my second question and that's what I'm
even more interested in is did the
wiretapping of Rajaratnam begin because
of speculation about his association
with terrorism in Sri Lanka giving aid
financial aid to the Tamil Tigers is in
other words Rajat Gupta collateral
damage for something
that the government was interested in
uncovering well to your second question
Subramanyam Swamy certainly feels that
you know he he told me that he wrote a
letter in 2006 to the US State
Department saying look Rajaratnam is
funding
you know the tunnel Tigers and and
Subramanyam Swamy if if you haven't read
the book was actually also the person
who wrote the recommendation to righteth
Gupta when he applied to Harvard
Business School from IIT and he felt
that he he had sort of you know paved
the way for the feds to start looking
at-at Rajaratnam I don't think I think
they were again you know I think it's
sort of the sausages far Messier the
sausage making is far Messier I think I
think there were two parallel
investigations going on by two competing
US Attorneys offices of Raj Rajaratnam
one was the insider trading
investigation that was happening in the
Manhattan US Attorney's Office and the
other was the investigation in the
Eastern District into the Terrorism
activities and the Manhattan US
Attorney's Office which is known as the
sovereign district of New York
eventually won out and the insider
trading case went forward and to your
first question I think Rajat saw
Rajaratnam as someone who could help him
make up for lost time in terms of wealth
creation Rajat had this wonderful
rolodex he talked to people about
wanting to quote-unquote monetize his
rolodex what did what did Rajaratnam
need he needed he needed more money to
manage
and so Rajat saw himself is as you know
possibly teaming up with him and and you
know making that into a lucrative
venture for me you know there's that
point where you talk about how the
balance of power between the two shifted
I mean you know Rajaratnam being very
you know wanting right to get plugged
into those higher circles and then when
Rajat gets the KKR offer
he asks rajaratnam you know what do you
think and he's asking him for his advice
find that so do you think that that
balance of power had shifted and
Rajaratnam had the upper hand you know
what at the stage when the whole thing
blew up yeah i do i do i think i think
when Rajat first you know got close to
Rajaratnam I think he thought he I think
he thought he came from a position of
superiority I mean he was the one who
had you know the the great contacts the
remarkable rolodex but by the time you
get to that conversation you know he's
he's he's asking here's a man who his
entire life had been giving you know
advice to other corporations advice to
boards he was the one who had actually
worked at the preeminent firm you know
in the financial services industry and
here he was asking someone who never
actually you know succeeded in a in a
you know in a firm like like KKR you
know for advice on whether he should
take this job and sort of a stunning
turn of events gave me go at the back
please dead right at the back so my
question is related to Rodgers early
career I mean from his college days in
IIT Delhi so
he probably graduated sometime in late
60s or early 70s if I'm not wrong 1971
right so and I've read everywhere that
Rajat comes from a humble background
where he probably had financial troubles
and at home how could he afford to go to
Harvard Business School he got a
scholarship okay beautiful okay
plus it's this related question is how
did how did Rajat manage to grow inside
McKinsey I am assuming that once again
that there are not many Indian Americans
at Mackenzie at that time was it
primarily during the late 80s that the
McKinsey board recognized that there's
probably ample opportunities outside of
the North American and European markets
so do we need someone who will go out
and the Asian markets to grow it so was
that the primary criteria wasn't simply
the best in the deep that he was
promoted I mean you have to remember
Mackenzie's apartment partnership and so
Rogers got the top job because he was
elected by his partners so there was no
board or anything appointing him and I
think one of the reasons Roger was
elected to the top job is that in in the
early 90s again there was this
generational split at McKinsey there was
the old guard that was represented by
people like Don wait and her penciler
and there was a new and up-and-coming
guard and Rajat was the perfect
candidate you know he was thoughtful he
was soft-spoken he was non
confrontational and I think the new
guard
you know gravitated around him and I you
know Jeff Skilling who was at McKinsey
at the time you know and was actually
you know people laughed but he was very
I had a lot of correspondence with Jeff
Skilling and he's a beautiful writer and
very eloquent and very smart
and he you know sort of laid out the the
landscape at Mackenzie during the during
the 80s and 90s and the and the tensions
between these two different generations
and I think Rajat came out of that fight
successful Geri veranda I'm Asian but
not Indian very obvious rate your
comment please on how the reforms in the
battle three banking reform would have
affected many of these events and more
importantly the future of those
financial wizard want to be I'm talking
about specifically about the
transparency brought about by the Basel
three right right I'm not sure the
transparency brought about Basel three
would have affected these insider
trading cases I'm not sure how that
would have that would have affected it
to be honest with you hi Anita hi we've
talked a lot about Raj Rajat Gupta I'm
curious just to hear from you more about
Raj Rajaratnam and his motivations and
kind of just the dynamic of him and his
family and also wrong and rajaratnam who
is now facing prosecution right what do
you think is going to happen there if
you have any comment right here um you
know Raj Rajaratnam to use his own words
would say I'm a rogue okay and I'm a
rogue yeah and I think that's that's
what he was he liked to he liked to push
the envelope wherever he could he liked
to play people you know there's this
episode in the in the relationship
between Rogers and Raj where it's at the
end of 2006 and and Raja has arranged
this high interest loan for his friend
Ramesh Mangal
and they're they're part of a consortium
to buy a bank in South India and the
loan isn't paid back in time and Raj
sends Rajat an email saying you know if
the money doesn't money doesn't arrive
I'm cancelling all further lunches
regarding Taj capital which of course
was the the South Asian money manager
that that Rogers was trying to build and
so so Raj had this you know a keen sense
of people he was he was he was very
street smart you know he could do
circles around the McKinsey men and in
terms of ranking which is Rogers brother
it's interesting to see that Rankin is
taking a very different approach from
his brother to his recent indictment on
charges of insider trading it appears
that he's trying to work out a plea with
the US Attorney's Office I suspect if he
does plead guilty he will just plead
guilty and not cooperate because if he
was to cooperate he would also have to
to tell give the prosecutors information
about about his brothers and there's
still one brother RK that you know they
they would be interested in building a
case against you know I know there's
lots of hands they were going to take a
last question from that gentleman there
and then you know at this rate Anita
you're going to be reading out I mean
virtually disclosing the whole book so
we'll just take a last question I'm not
sure it's actually a question it might
be just a comment but the warrant
comment was first of all I never
consumed Indian I never thought about it
and I was very interested in the case
and I and I share a lot of people that I
know never really said Indian I'm not an
Indian
and I didn't discuss this with any
Indian so I wonder whether maybe it's
just like a Indian theme like it's just
like my parents a Nigerian and I work in
the in financial crime compliance so
it's you know it's I'm always just like
oh god Nigerians and I wonder if it's it
so so I wonder if it's this Indian thing
where it's like Oh an Indian like
because and the other comment that I had
was um if this is just like a Stewart
thing I mean the son of the stereotypes
of the Evette they're docile they're
hard-working something bad I mean I
wonder if this is actually I don't want
to say progress but I mean I'm really
not trying to be funny okay so I mean
and this is just outside I wonder if
it's just I'm listening everybody talked
about how it kind of have a very good a
good stereotype attached to you and now
here's just one bad case I guess I don't
know if Michael my Toma who just got
indicted is an Indian but ya know I mean
this is the second one but I mean I
think a neat I don't know whether you
have any sign of comment or we can just
close this at this point and Anita is
going to be available now to sign copies
of a book if you're interested in
purchasing it and thank you so much
anything that was fantastic thank you
very much